[Musique]
nous sommes en 1933
franklin delano roosevelt ex gouverneur
de new york devient le 32e président des
états unis
c'est un président de crise car à
l'époque 12 millions d'américains sont
au chômage
c'est une personne sur quatre dans la
population active réformes économiques
l'injection de milliards de dollars
roosevelt ne regarde pas à la dépense
pour relancer l'économie et l'emploi
c'est le fameux new deal la nouvelle
donne dans les effets rapides finalement
du new deal hausse a été de remettre
beaucoup de chômeurs au travail
notamment du programme de travaux
publics financés par l'état la création
aussi d'un système de sécurité sociale
ont de faire en sorte que les gens qui
perdent leur emploi peuvent recevoir de
l'argent de la part du gouvernement un
souci du sort des américains qui semble
trouver son origine dans un terrible mal
qui ronge l'homme
quelques années avant qu'il devienne
président la polio cette maladie
finalement qui lui a donné l'impression
sur le coup que la qui n'aurait plus
d'avenir politique lui en quelque sorte
au contraire et ça lui donner courage
finances volant sa politique et celle de
donner une empathie aussi un peu plus
grande
riendeau pour arrêter cet habile
communicateur qui parle à ses
concitoyens par le biais d'un média
qu'il affectionne particulièrement la
radio la seule chose que nous ayons à
craindre c'est la crainte elle-même
dira-t-il et comme une crise n'arrive
jamais seul la deuxième guerre mondiale
est venue secouer le président d'un pays
qui jusqu'ici s'était replié dans un
certaine isolationnisme après l'attaqué
japonaise arabe
l'engagement dans le conflit du
président francophile va se solidifier
[Musique]
en pleine guerre en europe son esprit
combatif et de négociations avec les
grands leaders l'emmènera notamment à
québec et ensuite à la conférence de
yalta pour mettre fin à la seconde
guerre mondiale un conflit dont il ne
verra pas la fin officielle puisque en
mars 1945 il prête serment pour son
quatrième mandat
mais quelques semaines plus tard
terrassé par une hémorragie cérébrale à
63 ans il rend son dernier souffle 76
ans plus tard alors que son mandat
commence joe biden cite le président
roosevelt nature à masquer leur wild ou
un point faire notre part comme le
disait roosevelt by john est un autre
président de crise
en queue de pie donne on peut parler de
polarisation outrance la société
américaine la crise la coved 19 qui
s'accompagne d'une crise économique
également et tout comme avec roosevelt
en 1930 on se pose dans les années 30 on
se pose des questions sur la survie même
du régime démocratique aux états unis et
parce qu'on ne se dit pas ce qu'on est
dans un contexte où on a perdu confiance
de plus en plus grande envers les torts
dans les institutions de l'état à
travers les méga programmes de relance
économique de joe biden en 2021
certains éléments nous replonge dans
l'air roosevelt ensemble voir finalement
avec la taille de nos pouvoirs ces
grands programmes qu'il propose aux
américains
certes un loto à l'esprit du new deal et
il faut quand même mentionné que c'est
un curieux retour de l'histoire à qu'on
pense que pie xii n'est pas président il
est le seul président en fait soit née
pendant la présidence de rose et un
empire on triture quelque sorte ce n'est
une boucle qui vient de boucler une
boucle qui relie deux présidents somme
toute assez différent l'avenir nous dira
si la marque sera aussi forte pour les
deux hommes
ce qui est sûr c'est que le règne de joe
biden ne durera pas aussi longtemps que
celui de roosevelt qui a tenu le pouvoir
pendant 12 ans ce n'est pas forcément
mathématiques
vu le grand âge de maiden mais c'est que
depuis la mort de roosevelt le nombre de
mandats présidentiels est désormais
limité à deux
[Musique]